The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We're going to
cover hashing next time.
Now we're Going to
focus on pset three
because I heard
pset three is hard
so we're going to look at the
code and try to understand it.
AUDIENCE: This course is hard.
PROFESSOR: I've tried
to make it easy.
I really tried.
How many people
recognize the code?
Does this look familiar?
One, two, three.
Everyone else got
stuck on question one?
I'm not going to give you
the answers to the psets.
We are going to--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
We're going to look at
the code and understand
what it does because once
you understand what it does
you can understand
how to modify it.
All right, before I do
that, any questions?
And I might not answer
them right away,
but I will keep them in mind
while I go through the code.
Are there any
specific pin-points.
AUDIENCE: The types.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Covered in five minutes.
Oh well.
The first thing that
I want to talk about
is sweep line algorithms.
We're asking you to implement
the sweep line algorithm
and we're giving you one
that is horribly inefficient.
Suppose you have some line
segments that look like this.
Sorry, drawing isn't.
They look like this.
And suppose you want to find
the intersections between them.
Now let's figure out
what the algorithm
that we gave you does.
Did people look at
the trace for that?
Not the good trace, the trace
that's output by the algorithm
that we gave you.
Does anyone understand
what that does.
AUDIENCE: I kind of get it.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: I think what it does
is it just hits through all
the horizontal lines and it goes
through all the vertical ones.
First it goes through
all the horizontal lines
and what does it do with them?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: They get bolded
in the visualizer which
means they're added
to the range index.
So one, add all the
horizontal lines.
And two-- oh you said it goes
through all the vertical lines
after that.
Any idea what it does?
AUDIENCE: It looks
for intersections.
PROFESSOR: When he looks
at a vertical line segment
you'll see some blue
square and you'll
see some segments
that are green.
This is a query
to the range index
and the green segments
are the answers
and the blue square is
the range that's queried.
First add all the segments
to the range index
and then do a query.
In principle sweep
line algorithms
have some geometric inputs.
For example, a bunch of lines.
And conceptually they
have this vertical line
that they sweep across the plane
all the way from minus infinity
to plus infinity.
Now if you try to sweep
a line continuously
from minus infinity to
plus infinity in code
it might take forever.
We don't really do it that way.
The way we do it
in code is you know
when something interesting
is going to happen
and you only simulate what
happens to the sweep line
at that point.
In this case the sweep line
starts at minus infinity
and then all the
horizontal segments
are added to our range index.
And then as the sweep line
goes across the plane, when
it hits a vertical
segment a query happens.
The only times when
the sweep line stops
is first, at the beginning to
add all the horizontal line
segments, and then every time
it hits a vertical line segment.
We know this ahead
of time so we can
compute a list of
all these coordinates
of interesting things.
And then we can sort them
and then go through them
and simulate the behavior
of the sweep line that way.
If you look at the code
listing at events from there,
this is the gist of it.
This is what it does.
It compiles a list of events.
The first key in each
event is the x, is that x?
Yeah. x like this, y like this.
The first case, the
x-coordinate of an event
and by sorting
that list of events
it will then process
them in order.
Events from there is responsible
for looking at all the wires
and compiling events.
How does an event for a
horizontal layer look like?
Can anyone tell me?
Sorry, for a horizontal wire.
AUDIENCE: It will run
across [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: First off it
looks like a list, right?
It's a regular python list.
And I will try to call it vector
so that we don't confuse it
with a big list
of all the events.
You said the first thing
is the leftmost point.
Right?
If this segment, for
example, starts at minus 100,
this one starts at minus 95,
this one starts at minus 90,
and this one starts at minus
50, by the way not to scale,
then the leftmost
point is minus 100.
Right?
This is the first
element in the vector.
And that's computed
on line four where
it goes through
all the segments,
looks at all the X-coordinates
and chooses the minimum.
What's the next
thing in the vector?
We don't have to understand why.
We'll go through why in a bit.
I'm just interested in what?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
PROFESSOR: Zero.
Excellent.
PROFESSOR: After that
there is a wire ID.
Each wire gets a unique ID,
that's a number between zero
and the number of wires.
Say this is one, two, three.
This is going to be one.
And then I have the string add.
And then I have the
actual wire object.
What does the vector look
like for a query event?
Sorry, what does it look
like for a vertical wire?
I'm giving away
some of the answer.
Bad, bad, bad.
All right, vertical wire,
look at the code and.
AUDIENCE: It keeps
the left [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Of the wire.
OK.
And?
AUDIENCE: It keeps the
x-coordinate [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: A vertical wire will
have the same X-coordinates
for all the points
on the wire, right?
I don't really worry about
which coordinate it is.
This wire is at minus 50.
The first element here
is going to be minus 50.
What's next?
AUDIENCE: A 1.
PROFESSOR: A 1.
OK.
And suppose this is wire ID 4.
I'm going to have 4.
AUDIENCE: Query.
PROFESSOR: Query.
AUDIENCE: And the wire.
PROFESSOR: And the wire.
All right, what happens with
these in the init method, which
is not shown in
the code listing,
is after the list is put
together sort is called on it.
These are all compared
and then reordered
to be sorted according to
some ordering relationship.
Does anyone know what
the ordering relationship
is for Python lists?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It starts from
the first, from zero,
and the next it goes to
sort the same with as X 1.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Say if I have 1,
2, 3 and 1, 3, 2.
Sorry, and 2, 1, 2.
He's going to look
at the first element
and if they are different
than the one with the smaller
element is smaller.
1, 2, 3 as a vector,
sorry, as a list,
is smaller than
2, 1, 2 as a list.
If this guy becomes
one then they're equal.
Then it has to go
to the next element,
compare them and see if
they're different we have
an answer, if not
we have to keep
going all the way until
the end of the list.
This is called
lexicographic comparison
and this is the same ordering
that you have for the words
in a dictionary.
Right, if you think
of each letter
as an element in a list
and the word is the list
then this is how you look
up words in a dictionary.
The reason events
look like this is
so that sort would output
them in the right order
for the next state.
So, yes.
AUDIENCE: Does that mean
all the horizontal wires,
does that mean that they start
at same place even though that
they don't?
PROFESSOR: Yup.
all the horizontal
wires will be sorted.
All these add events will be
sorted before the query events.
Yup, very good observation.
This is what I'm
trying to achieve.
That's why I have this
special value here.
I go through some extra
effort to compute it.
I had to write an
extra line of code
so this is the
motivation for it.
The first key in the
vector is the X element
on the sweep line.
I could've also had the
very large negative value
that something that would
behave like minus infinity here
and that would
work just as well.
By computing the left edge I
don't have to deal with that.
I don't have to worry of
whether my negative infinity is
small enough, because if
it's not I will fail the test
and that's bad.
This is the x-coordinate at
which the sweep line stops
and something happens.
So if all the events are
different the x-coordinates
then I have my
ordering, I'm done.
Now what if I have two
events at the same time?
For example, what if I
have two vertical wires?
The x-coordinates are
going to be the same
so I need to use something
else to break the ties, right?
The first thing that I
use to break the ties
is all add events
have a zero here
and all the query
events have a one.
And the point of
that is if I have
two events at the
same x-coordinate,
if I have a query
and an add, I want
the add to happen
before the query.
If this is the
same this is going
to be different for
ad versus query.
Does that make sense?
This is how we order
events relatively
to each other on the same line.
Now suppose I have
these two wires,
they're both vertical so they're
both going to be queries.
They're both at the same index.
I need something else, and
that other thing that I have
is the wire ID which is
guaranteed to be unique.
I know for sure the
comparison will stop here.
And the comparison
had better stop here
because if the comparison
gets all the way to here,
wires aren't comparable so
the code is going to crash.
It stops here because the IDs
are unique, everyone is happy.
All right, do the events
make more sense now?
To complete the
picture if you look
at compute crossings,
lines nine and ten.
Line nine goes through
the vector-- sorry,
goes through the list of
events that have been sorted
and processes them
in order so sort
had better do the right job.
And then it extracts the
x-coordinate, that's here,
it extracts the event
type, that's here,
and then it extracts
the wire from here.
These guys really are just
there to help with the sorting,
they're never read afterwards.
AUDIENCE: Where are the
events actually sort?
I thought they just
put into order.
PROFESSOR: The events are
sorted in an init method that's
not here.
It's in the piece of
code but it's not here.
And that may be a hint that
you don't want to change it.
As in you don't need to.
All right, events
look like this.
Any questions about events?
Everything make sense?
Presumably when you write
your own sweep line algorithm
you're going to come up
with your own events which
are going to be different.
You're going to change
these methods to add
your own events to the list.
And then it's going
to be sorted for you
and then you're going to change
compute crossings to process
your events in the way that
they should be processed.
Let's look at the range index.
What do we store
in a range index?
AUDIENCE: The horizontal wires.
PROFESSOR: Horizontal wires.
Very good.
What's the point of storing
horizontal wires in an index?
AUDIENCE: That's when
you want to query,
the area has a line through it.
PROFESSOR: For the
algorithm that we gave you
how does a query look like?
Suppose I have this wire here
and I'm doing a query for it.
AUDIENCE: Just ask to
list horizontal wires that
are between that Y.
PROFESSOR: Between this guy's
top and this guy's bottom.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: A query
would look like this.
Basically all the
horizontal wires
that have their y-coordinates
between this guy and this guy.
Now if I have a wire that's
way up here or way down here
I know for sure that it's not
going to intersect this wire.
Right?
I don't care about it.
The range index helps
me eliminate some wires.
Now, will the range index
eliminate all the wires
that don't intersect
with this wire?
No, OK.
Why not?
AUDIENCE: Well in
this code it doesn't.
PROFESSOR: OK, in
We're only talking
about this code,
I'm not talking about
the solution code
that you guys have to implement.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't
because it never
removes the horizontal wires.
PROFESSOR: OK.
What's an example of a
query that would give me
some wires that don't
intersect my wire?
AUDIENCE: Like if they're
in between the y-axis,
they're, yeah but
they're not actually.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you mean.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Negative infinity
and infinity on the x-axis
would give you a bunch of
wires and not many of them
will intersect with
the vertical wires.
AUDIENCE: If the end were a
vertical wire, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
I understood this because
it matches what I drew.
I didn't understand the
minus infinity plus infinity.
AUDIENCE: Well if you think
about the x-axis on the bottom,
if you go from all the way
on the left to all the way
on the right you're going to get
a whole bunch of wires that are
short that--
PROFESSOR: Are you
talking about one wire
that's like that, or many?
AUDIENCE: If you're grabbing
from your range index.
PROFESSOR: The range index
has horizontal wires in it.
AUDIENCE: Right.
AUDIENCE: Are you assuming
that they're all short?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
But it's not necessarily true.
Some of them will be short.
PROFESSOR: You're saying a lot
of short horizontal lines--
you mean like this, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
That's what you mean.
AUDIENCE: You have
one intersection and--
PROFESSOR: A ton of
non-intersections.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
PROFESSOR: OK, cool.
Thank you.
Doing a range query
on this can give me
a lot of false positives.
That's why after
I get them I have
to make sure that
they intersect and I
can't just blindly output them.
These are bad false positives,
these are bad false positive.
Now let's look at how
the range index works.
Can anyone remind me of
what the range index does?
It's a data structure, right?
And it has some operations.
What are the operations for it?
AUDIENCE: It returns
everything between two values.
PROFESSOR: You have a list
operation where you give it
two values and it will return
everything inside the index,
in the interval between
those two values.
What else can I do?
AUDIENCE: It can also
tell you how many.
It returns those keys
and how many there are.
PROFESSOR: I have
the count and you
said that I have some
things in the index.
Right?
How do I get them in there?
These are queries,
I need updates.
AUDIENCE: Add and remove.
PROFESSOR: For the code
that they gave you,
what is the running time for
each of these operations?
AUDIENCE: It would be
constant had to be removed.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Add calls the pend.
Right?
So that is constant.
I will agree there.
AUDIENCE: To remove it you
had to shift everything.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Let's start with an example.
Say I have these keys
in my range index.
5, 8, 11, 13.
Suppose they're magically
inserted in this order.
If I want to remove two,
since this is an array
I have to shift
everything to the left.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: So that's.
AUDIENCE: Order and time.
PROFESSOR: OK.
How about list and counts?
What's the running
time for counts?
How does count work?
AUDIENCE: It's not just
through all of the keys.
PROFESSOR: Count goes
through everything and--
AUDIENCE: It has to
be order [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Cool.
Count goes through all
the keys, evaluates
the predicate that checks
whether they're in the range
and then it adds up one to
the sum for the right place.
How about list?
AUDIENCE: Also [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, that's
a list comprehension.
The code is a bit tricky,
but it pretty much
does the same thing.
It goes through the list
and it puts all the keys
that are in the
interval in the list.
Now let's look at
another version
on the next page of our range
index that is slightly better.
What's the rapid
variance for this?
How is it different
from the first one?
AUDIENCE: Sorted already.
PROFESSOR: Sorted already.
Very good.
The keys look exactly like this.
Right?
What is the running time for--
let's start with add or remove,
what's the running time
for add and remove?
AUDIENCE: N, order of N.
PROFESSOR: Why is it order of N?
AUDIENCE: No, oder log N.
PROFESSOR: Why is
it order log N.
AUDIENCE: Because if it's sorted
you can look in the middle
and do a binary search.
PROFESSOR: I can do a
binary search in order
to find out where
I insert something.
Right?
But what if I want to
insert zero in this?
AUDIENCE: Is it
log N plus order N?
Does that make sense?
Because you have to shift
all of the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So worst case if I have
to insert zero here,
I have to shift everything to
the right to make room for it.
Right?
So your first instinct was good.
Order N. And questions?
No more?
Cool.
How about remove?
AUDIENCE: Order N.
PROFESSOR: Order N.
Why is it order N?
AUDIENCE: You have to shift
left everything to the right.
PROFESSOR: Is this what
you were going to say too?
Same reason as before,
if I want to remove 2
I still have to move
everything to the left.
I can find the key that I
want to remove very fast
but then shifting
things is still
order N. OK how about count?
How does count work?
AUDIENCE: It's the
same thing, isn't it?
AUDIENCE: Binary
search so it's log n.
PROFESSOR: Binary
search, so it's log n.
If I look at the
count there it's--
AUDIENCE: It's
not though, that's
telling you how
many keys between.
AUDIENCE: So it's a
simple subtraction
to find the number
of keys between.
PROFESSOR: Count calls
binary search twice
and then it does a
arithmetic operation, yes.
AUDIENCE: It would be log n
because with the count where
the range is that's log n
because you have to actually
sift through it, but
binary search you have two
other operations and then
you just do a surprise.
PROFESSOR: Yep, thank you.
Very good.
This is log n because of
good old binary search.
How about lists?
I think you were
thinking ahead of lists.
How about lists?
AUDIENCE: You have to list every
single thing that you read.
AUDIENCE: You've got the
values you might potentially
have to [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Is it log n plus
the length of the list.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I was going to do a
nice long analysis
and there's the answer.
Log n plus, suppose you return
i values from the list, i.
Why does this matter?
If I have a range query from
minus infinity to plus infinity
I have to create a new
list, copy all these keys in
and return them.
That's order n.
I can't just say it's log n.
On the other hand, if the
answers to my list queries
are small, if
they're one element,
then it's going to take log
n time to do a binary search
and then order one to
produce the list if I
have a constant size list.
If I just say order n
I'm selling myself short.
It's a lot better if I
want to have short queries.
What would be the best possible
running time for lists?
If I had a magic algorithm that
works as fast as possible would
I be able to run
in order one time?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: Super fast
magic algorithm order one.
No, why not?
AUDIENCE: Because you still have
to find l and h in your array.
PROFESSOR: Suppose I
have some other data
structure, a super
magical data structure.
AUDIENCE: You can do
searches in order one time,
is what you're saying.
AUDIENCE: You still have
to have the contents of it
for what you're listing.
It would have to be order i.
PROFESSOR: Even if I
have a super magical data
structure where I can do
everything that I want inside
in order one time then
when I produce the output
I still have to
write the output.
This thing is
going to be omega i
and I can't possibly do
any better than that.
No matter what
running time you have
for list it has
to include this i.
Unless you're running time
is order i, in which case
i is smaller or equal to n.
Does this look right to you?
There is a small
bug in this code.
What if I do count of 4, 11.
Binary search returns,
if there's a key
there it will give me
the position of that key.
And if there's no
key it will tell me
where I should insert the
key if the key doesn't
exist in theory.
So if this is my array then the
positions are 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Count of 4, 11 would do a
binary search of 11 and see 4
and then it will do a binary
search for 4 and return 2.
Right?
Because if I want
to insert 4 I would
have to put it here and then
shift everything to the right.
And 4 minus 2 is 2
therefore it's broken.
AUDIENCE: Off by one block.
PROFESSOR: Off by
one block, right?
Well the interesting thing about
it is that I had this code,
we actually shipped this
code between Saturday morning
and Sunday evening and
it passed all the tests.
As we go to the next
section keep in mind
that this is broken
but it would still
pass the test for our problem
and we'll see why in a bit.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Count of 4, 11.
AUDIENCE: So
confined to them then
it says that when
you're down 5, right?
Four.
PROFESSOR: Four.
Binary search, if
it finds the key
it returns the
position of they key.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
4 divided by x, and 4,
4 would it have had two?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because it
tells me where to insert it.
AUDIENCE: OK, then it is.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well it
says 4 minus 2, right?
The last line is high
index minus low index?
AUDIENCE: Oh, well that's
wrong. [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So are you saying that
it tells you where to insert it
instead of actually
inserting it.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Binary search doesn't
insert the element.
It just tells me this
is where you put it.
And then if you look at add,
add inserts it right there.
That's why binary
search is done that way
so that that would work.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
a style question?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: The underscore
before binary search,
is that like saying private?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Wait, what
does private mean?
PROFESSOR: Private
means that it's not
part of the public
interface of the class.
If we're in a team and
we're working on something,
if I mark a method as private
that means if you use my class,
you're not supposed to call
it because I might change
it's name, I might
delete it completely,
I can do anything I want to it.
But if the method is public, so
add, remove, list, and count,
those are the API or the
public interface of the class.
I guarantee that as long as the
blit range index class exists
it's going to have an
add to remove a list
and the conduct will behave
in exactly in that way.
Once you have a class
with public methods
you're not supposed
to change them
because other people
might depend on them
and that would make
other people unhappy.
We said that this range
index holds wires.
Right?
So if you have these wires here
they're not really numbers.
I know how to compare
numbers, I don't
know how to compare wires.
That's not something that's
readily comparable, right?
We have to bridge the gap
between numbers or things
that are comparable and wires.
The way we do that is
the key wire pair class.
If you look at key
wire pair class
it has-- I will
write it as KWP here.
So it has a key and the wire.
Right?
That's why it's a key wire pair.
And if you look at the
comparison methods,
lines 11 through 26,
but if you look at 11
through 13 pretty much
everything else is the same.
Then comparisons are
done in a certain way.
So the first
criterion is the key.
If you have two key wire pairs
that have different keys,
then the one with
the bigger key wins.
Now if they have
the same key then
this field called wire
IDs is used to break ties.
So first key and then wire ID.
What's the wire ID set to?
And where?
Where would you set a
field in a nice class?
AUDIENCE: The constructor.
PROFESSOR: In the
constructor, very good.
Where is it set?
Line number?
AUDIENCE: 10.
PROFESSOR: Line 10.
So the wire ID uses the same
object IDs that we had earlier.
So each wire has a unique
ID that's between zero
and the number of wires.
This works when I insert
my wires into the index.
What's the key for
wires, by the way?
Where are wires inserted into
the index in the algorithm
that we have and what's the key?
The algorithm that we gave you.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The y-coordinates.
PROFESSOR: The?
Which one, I couldn't hear you.
AUDIENCE: The y-coordinate.
PROFESSOR: The y-coordinate.
Can you tell me which line?
The intuition is very good.
You want the wires to be
keyed by the y-coordinate
so that when you a range query
between this guy and this guy
you get these wires.
That's the intuition.
Now what's the code?
AUDIENCE: Line 13.
PROFESSOR: Line?
I didn't hear you well.
Line?
AUDIENCE: 13.
PROFESSOR: 13.
Wires are added to the
index when an event of type
add is processed.
Right?
Line 12 says if
event type is add
so that's probably what we want.
And line 13 adds it to the index
and builds the key wire repair
with the key, the
y-coordinate of the wire.
Now let's look back
at the keys and see
that we have two special
key wire repair classes.
Key wire pair l and
key wire pair h.
These don't want the wire.
Why would I make a wire key
pair that doesn't want the wire?
Why is that useful?
AUDIENCE: You have the minimum
and maximum wire at ease.
PROFESSOR: Very
good observation.
The wire ID for the
low key pair looks
like minus infinity and the
one for the high key pair
look like plus
infinity as long as I
don't have more than
a billion wires.
What do these things not have?
They don't have a wire.
So if you look at key
wire pair l and h,
if you look at the initializers
on lines two and eight,
they only take a key
they don't take a wire.
This is useful in
which situation?
Where do I want to create
an index key that's
not associated
with the real wire?
AUDIENCE: When you want
to make the list when
you want to do a query.
PROFESSOR: When I do a query.
Very good.
If I'm querying, if I have
this vertical wire, which
starts from minus
80 to plus 80 then I
would like to make a low key
that corresponds to minus 80
and a high key that
corresponds to plus 80,
but I don't have any wire with
a horizontal coordinate of 80.
Right?
A hackish solution
would be to make
fake wires with
those coordinates
but if I make fake wires God
knows where my system is going
to break elsewhere.
Instead the clean solution is
to have these key wire pairs
so that when I insert
wires I have a wire
and when I don't the
wire is set to none.
And the wire IDs are
these special values,
minus infinity
and plus infinity.
What's cool about setting the
wire IDs to minus infinity
and plus infinity?
AUDIENCE: It's so that
if you have a y of 80
this y is at negative
infinity so it's
going to take that y also
because its y value is
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: All right.
Cool.
If I have a real
key wire pair and it
has a wire whose
coordinate is 80
this is going to be bigger
than a key wire pair
l with coordinate
80 and it's going
to be smaller than a key wire
pair h with coordinate 80.
If you do a query
using this and this
it's going to grab all the
wires with coordinate 80.
Does this makes sense?
So what's cool about
this in terms of coding?
Do I have equal keys
in my range index?
Do I have to handle
multiple equal keys?
AUDIENCE: No because,
actually in this case yes.
PROFESSOR: Do I?
AUDIENCE: Because if you
have all the horizontal wires
then it's possible
that you have two
horizontal wires at the same--
PROFESSOR: If I have
two horizontal wires,
say this guy here
and this other guy
here, this guy here, what's
the key value pair for it?
Key wire pair?
Let's say the coordinate is
minus 95 and the wire ID is 2.
The key wire pair is
they key is minus 95
and the wire ID is 2, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: And then
for this other wire,
suppose the wire ID is
10, the coordinate is
going to be minus 95 then the
wire ID is going to be 10.
So how are they
going to compare?
AUDIENCE: Then that one
is less than that one.
PROFESSOR: Yup.
So even though I have two wires
with the same y-coordinates
of the key as far as the
algorithm is concerned
is the same, in
the implementation
the keys are artificially
different because I introduce
an artificial ordering on
the wires using that wire ID.
In Which case would I have the
same key inserted in my index
twice?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
If these two wires overlap,
say this guy ends here
and this guy ends here, and if
I put their keys into the index
they're still different.
AUDIENCE: Only if they're
the same wire ID would
they have the same--
PROFESSOR: OK, and when do two
wires have the same wire ID?
AUDIENCE: If one of them
was negative infinity.
PROFESSOR: Let's assume
that the infinities
were in the right way.
Yes?
No?
Wire IDs are unique.
Every wire has it's own wire ID.
Wires will never have
the same wire ID.
So the only case
in which you have
two equal keys in the index
is if you insert the same wire
twice.
Would you ever want to do that?
Probably not.
You're going to the same wire
twice from the range query
and that's not useful.
When implementing a data
structure for the range index
we don't have to
deal with equal keys
and that is nice because
that's less thinking.
Now when we do a query,
will the keys in the query
be in the range index?
AUDIENCE: Not necessarily.
PROFESSOR: How
would I do a query
if I want to do a query
from minus 80 to plus 80?
AUDIENCE: You grab all
the horizontal wires whose
y-coordinates are--
PROFESSOR: You're thinking
in the range index.
I'm thinking as the
client of the range index.
So you have this
range index class,
how would you issue a
query to the range index?
AUDIENCE: The list on this page.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I would call the list method.
And-- oh crap, I
thought I was going
to avoid doing that today.
l and h are keys, right?
How do I construct my keys?
AUDIENCE: Use key wire pair.
PROFESSOR: Key wire
pair left of 80--
sorry low, and key
wire pair high of 80.
So then I'm going
to get to these--
I don't have wires for
this 80 coordinate.
Sorry, minus 80 to
80 because that's
what the query looks like.
I don't have wires
for these coordinates
so I'm going to use
these special values
and this one is smaller than
all the wires with coordinate
minus 80 and this one
is bigger than all
the wires with coordinate 80.
Will these keys ever
be in the index?
Nope, we're only using
them for updates.
If you put this in
the index then when
you're getting it back and you
try to get the wire associated
with it you're
going to get none,
your code is going to crash.
If I have a query will
the keys in the query ever
being the index?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
That means fewer border
cases to consider
when implementing query.
All the keys in the
range index are different
and they keys in the query will
never be in the range index.
AUDIENCE: When
you do the count l
and h aren't in your range
index you have to count that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
In this case that's why the
code didn't fail any test.
Because I'm not using numbers
I'm actually using this.
So for the number
analogy this is
equivalent to when I'm
doing a count of 4,11 that
would get rewritten as count of
3, 99 and 11.01 and this works.
This is what these
two values are doing.
Except if you try
to do 0.99 and 0.01
that's brittle because you
might actually have those keys.
All right, does this make sense?
Any questions on this part?
Nope?
Yes?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is this thing
in a count off situation
where you have a
gap in the wires
but you still have a
[INAUDIBLE] associated with it
as it's going through it.
PROFESSOR: Sorry,
say that again.
AUDIENCE: So with that
example right there.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Are you
worried about the fact
that I'll have two equal keys or
are you worried about the fact
that these wires are crossing?
AUDIENCE: No that
they're not overlapping.
You have a wire and you
have a wire coming down
and you have another wire.
PROFESSOR: OK.
This is not going
to account for that.
You have to write the
better sweep line algorithm.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: What
I'm talking about
now will make your
range index faster.
Or it makes your range
index simpler to implement.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: This is magic
behind the scenes that
makes your code smaller.
You still have to implement
the sweep line algorithm that
makes sure that when
you a range query
it will either return less false
positives or ideally no false
positives.
And then the code
will be faster.
But then when you
do that, you'll
see that it's still slow
because the range index
that we have here isn't optimal.
Why isn't the range index
here optimal, by the way?
What can I improve about it?
AUDIENCE: Add and remove.
PROFESSOR: Add and remove.
OK.
We're using the comparison
model because it's
convenient to use
the comparison model.
You have complex objects to
implement those six methods
that you see in key
wire pair and bam.
You can do comparisons, you
can use any data structure
or algorithm that assume
a comparison model.
What's the penalty of
the comparison model?
What's the problem with it?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It will be
slower, or it will never
be faster than the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yup.
If I want to do a
sort that is n log n.
And if I want to do a
search that is theta what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Now what are the best
bounds that they have for these
if we can go outside
the comparison model?
Just to see if you guys are
paying attention in lecture.
So best running
time for sort if we
don't have to use
the comparison model.
AUDIENCE: n.
PROFESSOR: n.
OK.
Best running time
for search if we
don't to use the
comparison model.
AUDIENCE: It's order
one with [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Order
one, with hashing.
Can you do any better than that?
AUDIENCE: You can
code it as zero.
[LAUGHING]
PROFESSOR: Sort has
to output an array
of elements so it can
be faster than order n.
Search has to output yes
or no so it has to output
something so it has
to be order one.
So this is as fast
as it gets, we're
definitely not going
to go faster than that.
We have this extra
log n factor that we
pay if we use the comparison
model if we don't collect
more information about our keys.
But in return we
have the convenience
that all we have
to do is establish
an ordering relationship.
Does it make sense?
Cool.
Let's try to talk about
the list pseudocode, which
you might have seen
on the pset before.
And that's on the
last page here.
I can't give you a
proof of why it works,
but we can work together
to figure out how it works
and get an intuitive
understanding.
Let's get the keys
here and let's
assume we're using a regular BSD
for implementing a range index.
I'm going to put
my keys in a BSD.
8, 3, 2, 5.
OK.
List those two things.
LCA and no list.
Right.
What's LCA?
Suppose I want to list all
the keys between one and six.
First I'm going to call
LCA and get some answer
and then I'm going
to call node list.
What's the answer for LCA?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Node at three.
Key value three.
PROFESSOR: What is this?
What's LCA?
It's OK to give out an answer
to a dumb question on the pset.
So LCA is lowest
common ancestor.
Very good.
It's the lowest common
ancestor of what?
AUDIENCE: Subtree of values that
should be returned nodeless.
PROFESSOR: So usually you
have two nodes in a tree
and you want to return the LCA.
If I want to find out the
LCA of 2 and 5, that is 3.
LCA of 2 and 13, that's 8.
Now if the keys are not in the
tree what does the LCA give me?
AUDIENCE: It's
where they would be.
PROFESSOR: It's where they
would be if they were inserted.
Right.
So 1 would be inserted here
and 6 would be inserted here.
And then their LCA is indeed 3.
What does that tell me?
Why is that useful?
AUDIENCE: You can cut off a
bunch of the rest of the tree
so you don't have
to look at that.
PROFESSOR: A bunch of,
or the rest of the tree?
AUDIENCE: The rest of the tree.
PROFESSOR: The rest of the tree.
So if 1 is here and
6 is here, then I
know that all the keys--
sorry, so 3 is to the left of 8
so all the keys
to the right of 8
are going to be bigger
than 6, for example.
Right.
Because 6 is here
and it's under 8.
I can throw this away.
Now if this would be to
the left of something else,
because 1 is here I
know that all the keys
to the left side of that
thing would be smaller than 1.
This subtree has to have all
the keys between 1 and 6.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You don't
have to move 8, right?
Where would you move 8?
PROFESSOR: Yup.
So we only look at the
subtree rooted at LCA.
LCA is passed as an
argument to node list,
and node list seems to
do sort of an-- this
is a pre-ordered traversal.
You look at the key, you
look at the left node,
at the left subtree, you
look at the right subtree.
Except there is some magic
there and in some cases
it doesn't go and look.
Let's see what would a good case
where it doesn't go and look
like.
Let's get the same tree.
Suppose I want to do a
list between 4 and 11--
sorry between 4 and 10.
We'll the LCA of 4 and 10?
AUDIENCE: Eight.
PROFESSOR: OK, so node list
would have to start here.
Suppose I'm here and I go to 3.
I know 3 is smaller than 4.
Do I want to go left?
Everything to the left
of 3 is smaller than 4.
This entire subtree
can be pruned.
Now suppose I'm on the right
side and I'm at the 11.
11 is bigger than 10,
do I want to go right?
So if 11 is bigger
than 10 I never
want to go right
because everything
to the right of that is bigger.
OK so this is how pruning works.
Now if I'm at 3, can I stop?
I can't stop and exit completely
because on the right side of 3
I might have keys that
are bigger than three
and that are in my interval.
And in this example that
seems to be the case.
Let's look very quickly
at the intuitive way
of analyzing the
running time for this.
Suppose I have my LCA
up here and suppose
I go on a path from LCA
to L and then-- let's
not worry about the right,
about h. h is somewhere here,
the case is going
to be symmetric.
When I go down the path, after I
go here would I ever want to go
left?
If this node is before
a right turn then
I know that l is going to
be bigger than that node.
Right?
So I'm never going
to take a left turn.
This subtree be pruned,
this subtree will be pruned,
this subtree will be pruned.
Now if I go right
here, what happens?
AUDIENCE: It's node--
PROFESSOR: All
the nodes here are
going to be between l and LCA.
LCA is smaller or equal to
h so all these nodes here
are guaranteed to be nodes
that come out in my list.
All right, why am I doing this?
I was saying before
that I absolutely
have to have an
order i because I
have to produce the output list.
If we look at the
lines three and four,
line four outputs a key right?
Line four is definitely
order i and line three
is an if condition
so we know for sure
that line four is
only going to execute
four keys that are
between l and h.
This algorithm is going to
visit some nodes in the tree.
For example, if I have a list of
4 and 10 it's going to visit 8,
it's going to
visit 3, 5, and 11.
And for some of the
nodes that are visited
it's going to output them.
Right this guy gets output
and this guy gets output.
The nodes that are
outputs are order i.
Those are already
covered in the i term.
And in order to get the running
time what I need to know
is, how many nodes do
I visit that are not
part of the output.
Because if I end up visiting
the entire tree then
that's order n plus i.
So order n.
But if I only end up visiting a
few nodes outside of the output
then that might be a lot better.
And here I'm trying to
argue that I will only
visit a few notes
the outside the path.
In fact, for every
node I'm going
to visit at most of the node
and the node at its left.
And then everything to the right
of the path is between l and h,
so everything to the right
is going to be output.
Everything here is in
order i and everything here
is visited in that output.
And potentially everything
on the path as well.
So what's the height of a
path in a binary search tree?
Regular binary search tree?
OK, and worst case.
So worst case the
height is order n.
But we usually call it height
because on average, at least,
it's log n.
It's somewhere
between n and log n.
What is the running time for
lists in a binary search tree?
If you buy this argument here.
What is the running time?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You could say n plus
i and you're perfectly correct.
But we can make it a bit better.
What's the height of this path?
AUDIENCE: h.
PROFESSOR: H. What's
the running time?
AUDIENCE: h plus i.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Cool.
Does this make sense at all?
Is this too complicated?
AUDIENCE: That's the
running time for what?
PROFESSOR: This is the
running time for lists.
All right so, questions?
Is this too far out?
Did I lose you guys completely?
Makes perfect sense.
I like that.
AUDIENCE: It's oder
n plus i because it
could have up to any
nodes on it, right?
PROFESSOR: Yup.
AUDIENCE: And then it's
order i because you
have to add that
[INAUDIBLE] of nodes anyway.
It's order h.
PROFESSOR: I'm saying that it's
a binary search tree of height
h and if h is better
than n then I'm
going to do much better
than n and that's
why I'm putting that h there.
AUDIENCE: OK, that makes sense.
I think it's just a ltitle
confusing at that part,
but the [INAUDIBLE] makes
sense because of course
that's a smaller
node you're not going
to look at the
left portion you're
going to look at the
right because it's bigger
than your smaller
[INAUDIBLE], right?
So if you go to the
right, that means that--
PROFESSOR: Here I know that
l is on the left, right?
So l is smaller than this key.
Everything to the right of
this key is between l and LCA.
LCA is smaller or equal to h.
Everything here is
between l and h,
so all the nodes here
are going to be output.
All the nodes here count as i.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Now when I turn left
here, this is smaller than l.
This is smaller than l
because l is on the right.
This thing is
going to be pruned.
So I will visit the parent,
this node, and that's it.
I'm not going to look down.
And this is how the
nodes look like.
Everything that's to
the left of the path
is not visited, everything
that's to the right it open.
Any more questions?
I hope you get it
right on pset then.
Thanks guys.